MALE SPEAKER: Great to welcome
Rodney here to talk to us
about landscape photography and
his work in that field and
some of these great images.
I've got a number of them
scattered around my home.
And some of you may as well.
But it's great to have
Rodney here.
Thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
RODNEY LOUGH JR: You might want
to save your applause
until the end, because you never
know what you're going
to get, right?
My name is Rodney Lough Jr. I'm
apparently the most famous
guy you've never heard of.
I have--
I want to first thank Google
for having me out here and
John Nile--
no, it's really Neal.
It's not Nile.
I did that on purpose--
and Chris James from the
legal department.
Well, I better start my little
starter, my little clock.
And a lady by the name of Lisa
Brewer, who is one of my
people at the gallery I
have in San Francisco.
It's a 14,000 square-foot
gallery.
It's the single largest
photographic artist
gallery in the world.
Feel free to visit.
I've got some ground rules.
It's OK to laugh.
It's OK to clap.
Not so OK to boo.
OK?
Hopefully that won't happen.
I was born in 1960 in
Jacksonville, Florida.
My father was in the
Coast Guard.
And we moved around quite
a bit, because
he was in the military.
About every three years we
found ourselves in a new
location, in a new
exciting place.
And it's sort of a negative
and a positive, right?
When you move around a lot, you
have the opportunity to
make new friends,
meet new people.
It gives you this sense of
exploration that you don't get
normally anywhere else.
But by the same token, you don't
really have a whole lot
of lifelong friends.
My dad was an avid
outdoors guy.
He grew up in Colorado.
They used to take pack
mules out into
the middle of nowhere.
They'd spend two or three weeks
as a family on vacation.
I know that sounds completely
foreign to us today that
somebody would do anything with
a pack mule, but that's
what they used to do.
And so he instilled in
me this sense of
exploration, which is fun.
Honestly, it's fun.
Sweat is a good thing.
I got my first camera when
I was 12 years old.
And it was an old
Olympus OM-1.
If you're wondering why I'm
only walking from here to
here, it's because that's
the total width that
this camera can see.
I would normally walk way over
there just to watch all your
head's turn, like at a tennis
match or something.
But my dad's best friend,
Uncle Bill, he loved
photography, absolutely
loved it.
And Uncle Bill saw my passion
for following him around and
seeing what he was doing.
And he gave me his
old Olympus OM-1.
I started doing black and white
photography with Uncle Bill.
And my very first darkroom
was the bathroom.
I'm not joking, the bathroom.
I'd mix my chemicals
in the sink.
I would have a little teeny tray
that I would do the one
thing and then the
other thing.
And I would hang it up.
I would literally turn
on the light switch
to expose the material.
That was my first darkroom,
the bathroom, literally.
And I shot black
and white film.
Oh man, well, I still
do, right?
But about eight or nine years,
when I was 20, 21, somewhere
in there, I discovered that
black and white photography
became easy.
I don't know.
Is that heresy to say that in
the heart of Ansel Adams land?
I don't know.
But color--
OK, think about--
well, I should ask.
Can I ask a couple
more questions?
Any photographers in the room?
Oh, quite a few.
Any of you actually
know who I am?
Oh, a couple.
Sweet.
Hey, that Google stuff's
working.
How many people shooting film?
All right.
How many shooting digital?
Film is not dead.
I'm just saying that.
How many shooting digital,
thinking of going to film?
One guy.
Really?
Look, I'm not counting an iPhone
as a digital camera.
Are you guys?
I hope not.
I hope that's not what you're
counting, because
that doesn't count.
Not realizing I had any talent
for photography whatsoever, I
took the traditional route
and went to college.
I was always good in math.
Do I have any math majors
in the room?
Sweet.
My kind of people.
I left my pocket protector
at home today.
When I was going to school, I
met my wife at a dance during
the summer, a church dance.
Went back to school.
Missed her a lot.
Left my last semester of my
senior year to go back and ask
my wife to marry me.
She was stupid enough
to say yes.
I was lucky enough
that she did.
When I came back to school, I
got called in after a couple
weeks into the dean's office.
Anyone ever get called into the
dean's office for anything?
Yeah, I didn't think.
None of you.
You're smarter than I am.
And they sat me down and they
said, you know, something
about you is different.
We're not sure what, but you
used to be a C student.
You're getting straight A's.
What's the deal?
I don't know.
I don't have a clue.
A couple more weeks go by, maybe
almost a whole month.
I get called back in to the
dean's office, and he says,
something's different,
because your
professors, they love you.
And quite frankly, they didn't
really used to like
you all that much.
And I get called in another
three weeks, and he says,
would you stay on for
a master's degree?
You've got to take this
applications test.
You've got to take a
theory test just
to get in the program.
But we'd like you to get in.
And I'm like, oh no.
I'm pff--
are you kidding?
I'm so far in debt.
Anyone still in debt
for the college?
Yeah, me too.
The cheapest money
you'll ever get.
Take forever to pay that off.
Finally he says, look,
just take the exams.
So I took the exams.
I got like a 98 on the theory
and a 99 on the application.
And I was feeling pretty good.
I'm in the statistics
department, minoring in
mathematics.
I was so smart, I could
float across campus.
That's how smart I was.
Or at least that's
how smart I felt.
So they call me back in and they
say, have you ever heard
of the BYU outstanding
achievement scholarship?
Like I'd ever heard of any kind
of scholarship before.
Not-- no way.
They said, well, we applied
for it in your name.
Can you do that?
Are you--
what do we call that today?
That's like identity
theft, isn't it?
They said, well, you got it.
You just got the Brigham Young
University Outstanding
Achievement Scholarship.
I said, that's wonderful,
but what is it?
Oh, simple.
It pays for everything.
Everything?
Everything.
And we'll even give you
a job at $12 an hour.
Now realize, way back then, $12
an hour in the research
center was a lot of money.
So after I got through
school, I went in--
I did graduate, just so you
know, a master's degree in
statistics with a minor
in mathematics.
So from one geek to the rest
of my fellow geeks in the
room, you don't have to remain
the way you are.
There is life outside
of geekdom.
Because I'm not--
well, how do I put it?
Because I can speak
corporate--
and you all know what
I mean by that--
actually, no.
You guys have a pretty cool
atmosphere here, don't you?
It's not too back-biting,
I hope.
But because I could speak
corporate, and because I could
speak geek, I went up the
ladder pretty quick.
And within seven years I was
director of database and
research for an international
direct mail marketing company
in New Jersey.
Now, I'm from Oregon.
New Jersey is about as far away
from where I wanted to be
as I could possibly get.
Any managers in the room,
people who manage?
A few.
Well, the rest of you
are lucky, trust me.
Because managing is not easy.
It's kind of like wrangling
cats, managing kindergartners.
All right?
You do realize that we
haven't changed.
When you were in the sandbox at
four or five years old, and
you were a yanking that toy
away from that other kid
because it's mine, you
haven't changed.
You've gotten sneakier, but
we haven't changed.
Basically, we're
still the same.
Anyone know any Germans, I mean
born and bred, honest to
goodness Germans?
These people have no sense
of social space at all.
One day--
OK, write this down.
You're going to need
this later in life.
An hour--
I can't do this in an hour.
It's crazy.
I'll speed up a little bit.
Write this down.
If you want to run a successful
business, here's
how you do it.
You're going to have problems,
so you have to
identify the problem.
Then you have to fix
the problem.
Then you have to not do
the problem again.
That's it.
That's how every successful
company on the face of the
plant operates, including
mine.
Identify the problem.
Fix the problem.
Don't do the problem again.
Every day as a manager,
I would have people
coming into my office.
We have a problem,
and Susie did it.
What are you going
to do to Susie?
Oh, come on.
Really?
So one morning Jens--
born and bred, Munich--
comes in.
And Jens is like this
close to my face.
He's so close.
And he's screaming about
something Susie has done, so
violently that the little
spit balls are
hitting me in the face.
I snapped.
I did.
Jens, can you hold that
thought for a minute.
I'll be right back.
I marched down to the senior
VP of marketing, who I
reported to.
She reported to the owners.
Now realize that this time
I was in charge of
$164 million in sales.
I know that means nothing to
you guys being from Google.
That's like your budget,
isn't it, $164 million?
I had 30 people reporting to me
in 13 different countries,
and I snapped.
I went down to her and I said,
I'm going to be leaving.
She goes, what happened?
I told her the spit balls.
She said, no, you can't leave.
I'm like, it's still America.
I'm pretty sure I can.
She goes, how much more
money do you want?
What?
Is that all I had to do to get
a raise, threaten to leave?
Holy crap, I wish I'd learned
that lesson sooner.
I said no, no, no, no.
I can't do this.
Well, when are you going
to leave, she asks.
About five minutes,
because I'm done.
I helped them find
a replacement.
On the drive home--
oh, I should back
up a little bit.
When you manage people, you're
sort of expected to do social
events of some kind, right?
We love to barbecue.
If you ever come up to Oregon,
you want a good barbecue, just
call ahead so we can vacuum and
get the barbecue ready.
People would come over
to the barbecue.
They'd see something hanging on
a wall, and they'd be like,
oh, that's amazing.
Where did you buy that?
Buy it?
Are you kidding me?
I'm Scottish.
I made that.
That's what us Scottish
people do.
We don't really buy stuff.
We just make it, because
we're that cheap.
I'm sorry, frugal.
More of a Scottish
word, isn't it?
Frugal.
Get in my belly.
So on the drive home I'm
thinking to myself, what am I
going to tell my wife.
We got three kids.
They were paying me
$120,000 a year.
This is back in '95, OK?
That's a lot of money
back in '95.
And since I was in charge of
all the budgets and the
performance and the bonus
structure, guess
what else we made?
Bonus every time.
So that was like another
$30,000.
I'm at $150,000 a year.
We're living in the big house.
We got the sports
car, everything.
Pull in the driveway.
I get out.
I walk up the--
in the front door.
My wife hears the door
shut and she
says, you're home early.
Did you forget something?
I'm like, yeah, forgot
my life.
What do you mean by that?
Well, are you in a good mood,
because I just quit my job.
She goes, really?
So what are you going
to do now?
Well, thought I'd work on my
photography for a while.
Now, I knew I'd married the
right woman long ago.
But this just nailed
it for me.
And she can pretty much do
anything she wants--
I hope she doesn't see
this, because then
she'll know she can--
and I'll still stick with her.
Because she walks up, and
she gives me a big hug.
And remember how we talked
about being interactive.
You're going to have to
say aw in a moment.
She gives me a big hug, and she
whispers in my ear, it's
about time.
AUDIENCE: Aw.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: It took us a
whopping week to pack the
house and get out
of New Jersey.
And we moved to Colorado.
Now within the first five
minutes of this talk, you've
probably decided whether
you love me or hate me.
And I've got to be honest,
either way, I don't care.
Because I like me.
I like me.
I like the fact that I left
the corporate world.
I like the fact that I'm doing
what I love to do.
I even like the fact
I keep winning all
these ridiculous awards.
I've got so many awards
it's sick.
You've heard of sick
money, right?
People who have sick money.
I have sick awards.
People shooting photography,
more questions.
Anyone shooting medium-format
camera?
How about large format?
One dude.
You guys don't even know what
I'm talking about, do you?
You saw that picture of me
with the camera, right?
Imagine a camera so large that
the film is that big.
That's how big my film is.
Have you ever seen the old
camera with the bellows on
them, and you've got to put
your head under the hood?
Everything on the back
i a ground glass.
It's upside down
and backwards.
Have you guys seen this
kind of camera before?
That's what I'm using.
They still make them, but
they've stopped making my
film, which is kind
of unfortunate,
but I have a stash.
Because I'm on the Fuji film
talent team, I saw it coming.
I have hundreds of sheets of
film sitting in the freezer to
use down the road.
In order to be successful in the
business I do, you have to
have passion.
I think to be successful
in any business, you
have to have passion.
So my passion, what drives
me is I'm a soloist.
Right?
I love being out in the middle
of nowhere by myself.
Why?
Well, let me ask.
Anyone ever do that?
Show of hands.
Out in the middle of nowhere,
by yourself.
Nothing else like
it, is there?
Pure silence.
So quiet you can hear the
ringing in your ears, which is
the onset of tinnitus, which
comes with age unfortunately.
Most the time I'm about
11 miles or so back.
Oh my gosh, I'm only
halfway through.
This is crazy.
How am I going to
pull this off?
Does Google have a mission
statement?
Anyone know it?
Show of hands, who knows
it by heart?
Managers, you're going to want
to take note of the people who
didn't raise their hands.
My mission statement--
now realize, if I had wanted
to make money, becoming an
artist was probably not
the smartest move, OK?
My mission statement is to
enrich people's lives by
bringing Rodney's nature-based
art into every home and office
in the world.
It's one sentence.
It's a long sentence
and probably not
grammatically correct.
I'm a math guy, not
an English guy.
But if you get rid of the
rhetoric, Rodney, Rodney,
Rodney, and you boil it down to
its simplest form, enrich
people's lives through nature,
that's what I'm seeking to do.
I've been fortunate enough that
it seems to be working.
But it only works because
I have the passion.
I think I have time to
tell you this story.
No I don't.
I'm sorry, I don't.
I don't.
Normally I give convention
talks at Las Vegas or
something, and they're two
hours, three hours.
So to try and smush into
an hour is hard.
My son--
I'm Rodney Lough Jr. That means
there was a senior.
And that means, unfortunately,
there's a "the third."
So uno, dos, tres.
We called him Trey.
He doesn't even know how to
spell Rodney, because we've
called him Trey his
whole life.
Trey's 19.
He's got a fourth-degree black
belt in taekwondo.
He's the youngest master to ever
receive that honor in the
United States.
Even I don't mess with
him, and I'm a lot
bigger than he is.
But that's probably because
I love him, right?
It's a father thing, I guess.
Trey comes to me the other day,
and he says, dad, you're
considered the best in the
world at what you do.
Why?
How is that?
No one had--
I'd been asked--
I've been interviewed gobs.
No one's ever asked
me that question.
I thought, that was
a great question.
Why?
I thought about for a little
bit, and I thought, hm,
because I don't think I am.
Now that sounds crazy, right?
A piece in the Smithsonian, an
award from the United Nations.
I got something from the
US Senate, sick awards.
But why?
Why am I the best in the
world at what I do?
Because I don't think I am.
It constantly means that I'm
improving and looking at not
what's right but looking
at what's wrong.
It's easy to stand in front of
a large mountain at sunrise,
with the thing just going off
and the stream in the
foreground and everything's
perfect.
And it's yelling at you,
photograph me.
Please photograph me.
Look how magnificent I am.
Those are easy.
The in-between stuff, kind of
not the big mountains, just
sort of uh, a little
more difficult.
The intimate stuff,
really hard.
But in every one of those cases
I don't look at what's
right with it.
I'm constantly examining
what's wrong.
I don't know if that makes
me weird, but it's got
me where I'm at.
Oh my gosh.
OK, my studio--
I have an 18,000 square
foot studio.
It's just a teeny little
photography place.
I've got a tango drum scanner,
where I convert my film from
analog to digital, because you
can't even get print film for
enlargers these day.
Everything has to be switched
over and converted to digital.
I have two backup scanners.
I've got a 52-inch Colex
type C processor.
Is this going over
everyone's head?
Anyone know what I'm
talking about?
I got some over my heads.
And I got a couple people
saying, I don't understand.
But that's OK.
It basically allows me to go
like this, [WHISTLE], huh,
that's magnificent, get out my
camera, come back, [WHISTLE]
too-doo-loo.
Put it on the wall and
we all go, ahh.
Because that's it, right?
Hah.
That's what I do, try
and enrich people's
lives through nature.
The only way I can do that is
when I have that sensation,
try and get it on the
wall so you guys
can have that sensation.
Long story short, I got
a remarkable studio.
You guys are welcome to
come up and visit.
Like I said, just call ahead
so we can vacuum.
I do have time for one story.
When I do these photography
workshops every year--
people come on these photography
workshops.
They pay me, I think, outrageous
sums of money to
come and hike along.
People say, what do I get
for my 2 and 1/2 days?
Get to hang out with me.
That's what you get for
2 and 1/2 days.
Now I will tell you,
I wear you out.
Every night you're like
oh, I'm exhausted.
But it's so much fun.
Well, in order to do these
workshops up in Glacier
National Park in Montana, you
have to have taken this bear
encounter course.
And they teach you how to deal
with bears, when you come up
on them in the wilderness.
You take a submissive posture.
You're not loud.
You kind of talk
to them softly.
When they're not watching you,
you back away slowly.
The moment they take
interest, you stop.
They give you all
these scenarios.
I was up in British Columbia,
by myself, on this teeny
little island called
[? Mala Illa Coola. ?]
And I'm pretty sure I
just butchered it.
And I've moored my boat
on the beach.
I'm hiking down this one little
trail that's got about
this wide, blackberry bushes
going off on either side.
And every, I don't know, eight
feet is a pile of bear scat.
And I'm a guide in Glacier.
I know how to handle bears.
Never had to really, but
I've been trained.
Come around this little-- and
I'm doing all this stuff.
I'm clapping my hands.
Hey bear, here I come.
Come around this little corner
and right there is the butt
end of a little black bear.
And I'm thinking to myself,
this is not something that
they teach you in the bear
encounter course.
What happens when you come up on
the butt end of the little
black bear?
Because if you turn and go the
other way, and it hears you,
the whole fight/flight
thing kicks in.
The bear attacks you.
It kills you, rips
your jugular out.
I might be exaggerating a
little bit for effect.
But it's probably not good.
So I'm thinking to myself,
what can I do?
I know--
true story--
as loud as I could, I
yelled, hey bear.
And at the same time I slapped
it in the butt.
The bear went, oh,
his eyes huge.
[SCRATCHING]
Now I'd gone to
[? Mala Coola Ola ?]
to photograph this old totem
that had fallen down.
And I found the totem,
and it was really--
didn't look that great.
So I thought, all right, I'm not
going to photograph this.
And I don't know how--
Is the mama bear around, because
this bear wasn't that
big, but it was big enough.
And I decided that I was
not going to go back
the way of the trail.
I actually went around the
outside sandy, rocky edge of
the island to get back
to the boat.
All right, single biggest
difference between me and
other photographers is that
I don't fake anything.
I'm actually famous
for not faking it.
My goal is to get back
to what I saw.
Now listen carefully, because
it's been interpreted many
ways, but you've kind of got the
horse here, so you can ask
the horse directly.
My goal is to get back
to what I saw.
How I get there, I don't care.
I just want you guys
to see what I saw.
People ask me all the time,
did you Photoshop that?
Now Photoshop, just so you
know, is not a verb.
OK?
What they're really asking
is did you fake it.
No, I didn't fake it.
Anyone know what a crescent
wrench is?
Show of hands.
A crescent wrench?
It's the wrench where it's got
the little dial on it, and you
twist it left--
up or down, and it gets
wider or smaller.
And they make little
teeny ones.
And they may gigantic ones.
Very, very useful wrench.
Now the guy who designed the
crescent wrench probably never
thought that it would be used
as a murder weapon, but I'm
pretty sure it has been.
Oh.
The guys who designed Photoshop
at Adobe probably
never thought it would be used
as a murder weapon, but I
personally have seen it be
used as a murder weapon.
So the question is, is the
crescent wrench, the engineer
of the crescent wrench
the problem?
Or is it an issue of the
integrity of the user?
The guy who uses the crescent
wrench like it was designed to
be used, the same could be true
about Photoshop, right?
Is it Photoshop that's
the problem?
Did you Photoshop that?
Well, technically I had to.
I have to use Photoshop to
color balance it and get
things back to the way I saw.
No different than being in a
traditional darkroom where you
change the color wheels, or
you dodge or burn, or you
create contrast masks or--
I'm going over your
heads, I know.
It's OK.
No difference.
It's just you're doing
it digitally.
That's the only difference.
So is Photoshop the issue?
Or is it an issue of the
integrity of the user?
How many people think
it's Photoshop?
Sweet.
I've got converts already.
I can tell.
How many think it's about the
integrity of the user?
It's a really stupid
question, right?
If you went to college, you
can't get that one wrong.
My definition of a lie is any
communication given from one
to another with the
intent to deceive.
Right?
That's a lie.
That's its most simple,
basic form.
It can be any kind
of communication.
It could be verbal.
It could be nonverbal.
It could be video.
It could be written.
There's gobs of commun--
their body language.
Does that make me look fat?
Does this dress make
me look fat?
No.
I wouldn't touch that with
a 10-foot pole, ever.
But see, I think that when you
die there's an up escalator
and a down escalator.
I'd kind of like to be
on the up escalator.
So lying's not really high
on my to-do list at all.
Do you know you have talent when
your friends and family
tell you you have talent?
Does that count?
Probably not.
What about when someone
pays you and you can
make a living at it?
You think maybe then
you have talent?
I think that every one has
been given talents.
Not everyone knows what
their talent is.
They haven't discovered
it yet.
But I think we've all been
given different talents.
Imagine a world where you wake
up one day, and you've been
working in the produce
department at some grocery
store, and you decide, I want
to be a school bus driver.
Now I would never do that.
But in this Utopian world of
mine, you give your notice and
you go to the school bus driving
school, which is what?
Being taught by people who love
nothing better than to
teach other people how to
drive school buses.
I think everything would
still get done.
I think there are people who are
natural born tidy uppers,
if that's even a real word.
I don't even know.
Is that a real word,
tidy uppers?
People who walk around picking
garbage up off the ground or
straightening the papers
on your desk.
You didn't ask them to.
Every mother-in-law in the
world is a tidier upper,
because they come in to the
house and they clean all of
your shelves.
They stack all your plates and
your dishes in a certain way.
It's not the way you want it.
And you can't say anything.
They're tidier uppers.
Oh my gosh.
This is ridiculous.
OK, how many people in the room
are good at what you do?
Keep those hands up, because I
don't want to see the people
changing their minds.
How many of you are great
at what you do?
Put your other hand up.
Great.
Higher, so I can tell.
These are people who are
great at what they do.
For the rest of you, good
is the enemy of great.
Don't be good.
Be great.
Anyone ever hear of a guy by
the name of Jim Collins?
He wrote a book called "Good to
Great." Jim Collins wrote
this book, and he said, hmm, I
wonder if there's a way to
determine how businesses just
kind of go along, and then
they just shoot up at
a 45-degree angle.
And they've been doing
this for years.
And it's just within
the market trends
and blah, blah, blah.
What happened at that juncture
to cause them to go
from good to great?
And he thought, well, we could
design a research study, but
that would take 50 years, 50
years to come up with the
analysis and see what
the results were.
So instead he said,
you know what?
Let's go to the stock
exchange.
Let's look through that data.
We've got gobs of data.
And let's just see if
anyone did that.
Sure enough, they had.
Over all the years, they went
in and they looked at
different categories of
companies in different years.
And sure enough, boom.
So they asked a very
simple question.
What happened at
that juncture?
What took these companies
from just doing
whatever to being great?
I'm going to summarize a bit.
Normally I'd stretch this
out, but we don't
have much more time.
I want you guys to get it
though, "Good to Great."
They came up with what they
call the three circles.
I don't know why they call
them the three circles,
because they got nothing to
do with circles really.
They were three questions
put in a circle.
First question, what are you
better at than anyone else on
the planet?
This is important stuff.
You guys want to know how to
run a business and make
success in your life?
This is how you do it.
I wish somebody had demanded
I read this book
when I was like 12.
Of course, it hadn't been
written then, but you know.
What are you better at than
anyone else in the world?
So for our little company,
we sat around and
we discussed it.
And we came up with a very
simple statement.
We create the finest landscape
wilderness
artwork on the planet.
From click to ship, nobody
does it better.
And I know, because we get
all of our materials
from the same suppliers.
And I know what other
people are using.
And I know that I'm the only
one crazy enough to lug 120
pounds of camera gear up over a
12,000 foot mountain pass to
maybe get a shot.
No one's doing it
at our level.
Nobody on the planet is
even coming close.
So I'll stand on my soap box,
and I'll say, bring it on.
You want to put your piece
next to my piece,
come on, I dare you.
I've got my fourth-degree black
belt son backing me up.
Second question, what drives
your economic engine?
In other words, if you could
put a little box, which has
got profit in it-- and profit
is created through x.
x is the label on the box.
What would that x be?
So what drives your
economic engine?
We thought about it.
Didn't take that long
to figure out.
For us it's profit
per piece sold.
Every piece that we sell, the
most profit we can get out of
it, better for us.
There's lots of ways
you can do that.
I could trim my expenses
in payroll.
No one wants to hear that.
I know, times are tough.
I didn't do it.
Haven't done it.
You could beat up your suppliers
and get a better
deal on your raw goods
materials, right?
That will help increase
your profit.
Maybe you don't discount.
That would affect your profit.
So for us the answer is, what
drives your economic engine?
Profit per piece sold.
For us, pretty simple.
The last question that they
asked was they said, what are
you passionate about?
Because you have to have
passion in what you
do, or forget it.
Go home.
Choose something else.
For us it boiled down to our
mission statement, to enrich
people's lives by bringing
Rodney's nature-based art into
every home and office
in the world.
Great.
Now what do you do?
What they determined was if you
can take all those three
circles with questions in them
and overlap them into a little
Venn diagram in the middle, you
get this sort of little
not quite triangle.
But you know what I'm talking
about, right?
Come on, you guys are geeks.
Keep up.
Circle, little thing
in the middle.
If you can figure out what that
one thing is that ties
all the rest of what you
do together, you can go
from good to great.
So for the last four years we've
been sitting around,
figuring out, what
the heck is that?
What is it?
I don't know.
Well, we came up
with something.
We came up with what
I call Stand Here.
OK?
I have watched in horror, over
the years, where places I've
photographed that are
truly sanctuaries--
anyone that does the hiking
ever been to one of these
places where you just
sit there and
you know it's special?
It's special.
You just know it.
All you have to do--
If you haven't been there, I
can tell the rest of you,
stand-here.com.
You're going to want to go
there after you leave.
And then you're going to want
to Google all your people
through Gmail--
because I'm pretty sure that's
what you guys use--
and tell people about it.
The places I photograph
have started to
be trampled to death.
All right?
Anyone been to a
national park?
Sweet.
The first time you went to a
national park, you probably
went because your friends
told you.
Oh, you've got to go.
It's amazing.
So let's say it's Zion
National Park.
You drive to Zion
And you're sitting in the
parking lot, underneath the
Cottonwood trees, looking at all
the other cars, and you're
like, what's so great about
this Zion National Park?
They go into the visitor's
center, where they got the
bookstores.
And you look through the
postcards and the note cards
and the posters and the picture
books and maybe even
spend a few bucks and
get some of them.
And then you walk over
to the ranger.
And you lay them on the table,
and you go, where are these?
You guys know what the
ranger's job is?
No one.
All right, let me tell you.
The ranger's task is to
protect the resource.
That's what their mandate
is, right?
They want to protect it.
Why?
So it can be there for our
childrens' childrens' children.
I think it's a great mission.
So he's going to say to
you, I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I don't know.
I'm not going to say he's lying,
but he's lying because
of his mandate.
And I don't blame him really.
Not too much.
But he's going to
give you a map.
And on that map is going
to be like 80 spots.
Oh, this one's great.
And that one's great.
You've got to go here.
Check this one out.
I'm here to tell you that out
of those 80 places, there's
like four of them that
are truly special.
And there's another five
or six that aren't
even on that map.
And I know it from spending
my entire life hiking and
exploring and whatnot.
On one of these chat rooms, a
friend of mine sent me a link
to it, and it said,
Rodney Lough is--
he wastes all of his time
hiking around in
the middle of nowhere.
And maybe he finds something.
And maybe he doesn't.
That's incredibly inefficient.
I thought to myself, that's
kind of a ridiculous
statement, isn't it?
I mean, how do these
people think that
these places get found?
Google Maps?
Maybe, but how did
that get found?
Oh, right, your feet.
That's how they got found.
All right, Stand Here is
a social media website.
It's a mobile app.
It's a monthly syndicated
column.
And with our fingers crossed
and our toes crossed, it's
also going to be a TV show.
That's what we're working
on right now.
Because our mission is
to enrich people's
lives through nature.
If I can tell people where
these places are--
I believe that this concept of
keeping them secret and keeps
them safe is a false.
It's false.
I've watched it destroy
places.
I think the only way to protect
them is to create a
community of people who
understand how beautiful they
are and work and seek to protect
these few places that
are really out there in the
gigantic national park.
I'm not saying that the whole
park isn't pretty.
It is, but there are
special places.
Those are the ones we
need to protect.
So that's what Stand
Here is all about.
So if you guys have the ability
to help create Stand
Here, in the public awareness,
so we can protect the
beautiful places in our national
parks, by all means,
please help us do so.
Because we're taking all
of our funds and--
well, not all of them.
We have bills to pay, right?
But we're going to take money
and donate back to each one of
these places to protect them.
Did you know that when you
donate money to a national
park, you can tell them exactly
how you want them to
spend the money?
You can.
On this trail I want you to take
this segment right here
and I want you to improve
the trail.
Here I want you to make sure
that duh, duh, duh.
You can tell them exactly
what to do.
And that's what we're
going to do.
We're going to create a
community of people who care.
Being highly-educated,
intelligent people that you
are at Google, you must
certainly understand the
importance of what I'm
talking about.
Because guys like me are
going to die someday.
And the knowledge will die too,
unless it gets passed on,
and it's carried on from
generation to generation.
I know, it's something we've
heard before, but it's true.
You get to a point in your
life and you go, oh, if I
don't share this, it
could be lost.
I don't want to see
that happen.
Thank you, guys,
for having me.
Appreciate it.
I did it.
Any questions?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Have you been film all
your life, or do you also
mix in with digital techniques,
like capture
techniques?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: I've been
shooting digital--
or, I'm sorry, film since I
was 12, all the way up to
about three years ago.
A company had asked me to take
out a 65 megapixel digital
back and play with it.
I think what they wanted was--
they wanted me to say
it's as good as the
8x10, click for click.
And it wasn't, so I
couldn't do it.
And I gave it back to them.
And then about a year and a half
ago, they came out with
an 80 megapixel digital back.
And they asked me to go out
and do the same thing.
And it does not match, click
for click, with the 8x10.
But because of all the
techniques that are available
now, where you can take multiple
pieces and put them
together, I can actually
get something that is
very close to 8x10.
We're not quite there yet.
The moment they can give me
something that captures a gig
in a single shot, and it's
like the size of a credit
card, I'm all over it.
So I have started to switch,
because they
stopped making my film.
I've got no choice, sadly.
So I've got about 400
sheets of 8x10
film left in the freezer.
And then I've got this 80
megapixel digital back that I
put on a 4x5 pancake technical
field camera, because the
lenses have what's called
an image circle.
Basically what it can see.
And I can move that back within
that image circle, even
though I've applied a tilt or a
swing or a shift, which, for
most of you, doesn't
mean anything.
Anything else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You've got-- how many
sheets of film do you
shoot on a typical
hike for a day?
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat
the question?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Yeah, the
question was, when I go out on
a day hike, how many sheets of
film do I take with me, and
how many shots do I take?
Did I get that right?
It depends.
I can go out for three weeks and
not take a single thing,
because I just don't
find anything.
Or I can go out, and
in one evening
it just goes ballistic.
And I'll go through everything
in my bag.
But typically, if I'm a day
hike, I'll carry five film
holders with me, which
carries 10 sheets.
Because there's two sheets
per film holder.
And I can blow through
that in a day.
But it's $50 a click.
So I'm Scottish, right?
A pretty frugal guy.
And I evaluate it pretty good
before I rip up $50.
AUDIENCE: So do you usually
shoot just one
frame of each scene?
And then do you always
print them?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: The question
was if I just shoot one frame
or one sheet of film for
every composition?
No, not necessarily.
Rarely will I shoot
one piece of film.
Usually it's always two.
Because the first one--
I shoot both sheets of film
exactly the same.
And then I'll process one.
And then I'll look at it and
make a determination.
Do I need to push it or pull it
in processing, which means,
do I need to make it lighter
or darker in processing,
because I under-exposed
it or maybe I slightly
over-exposed it.
And I'll do that post.
But I shoot everything exactly
the same in the field.
I don't use any color filters,
no polarizers.
I do have a graduated neutral
density filter, which allows
me to hold back the
bright sky.
But because it's a neutral
gray, it doesn't add or
subtract any color,
it just adds-- or
actually subtracts density.
So it keeps the light
from coming through.
And then do I actually
print them?
Yeah, that was actually
in the section I
skipped over on the studio.
I've got my own LightJet
430 digital enlarger.
I can do up to maximum one
image, 50 inches by 10 feet.
And if I wanted to, I could take
that piece and stand it
vertical and then put
pieces together to
make it even larger.
Yep.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How do you
decide where to go?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: How do
I decide where to go?
When I first started, I did
these little outdoor art
festivals all over
the country.
And so I would end up usually
end up going, what's between
this spot and the next spot?
And that's kind of
where I went.
I haven't done those
in like 10 years.
But now I pretty much get
to go wherever I want.
Tomorrow morning I fly down to
Managua, in Nicaragua, because
the president is getting
one of my pieces.
And I'm there to
give it to him.
Because I went there last year
and photographed Nicaragua and
actually had a blast.
It was a lot of fun.
So it just depends.
Sometimes I get lucky, and
someone says, hey, you want to
go to Nicaragua?
I'm like, Yeah, sure.
Other times it's like, oh,
I've got to work in the
studio, so I can't.
But if it's going off some
place like tonight-- for
example, if we were anywhere
to the north, there's an
aurora alert.
I don't know how many
of you know that.
But if you were up in Anchorage,
you'd be watching
the Aurora Borealis tonight in
full swing, because it's at a
level four, which is big.
AUDIENCE: How many days a year
do you spend out in the field
photographing?
How many days in studio
developing?
And how many days talking
through the business stuff,
making sure [INAUDIBLE]?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: You are so
a programmer, aren't you?
Out in the field, not enough.
In the studio, too much.
What was the other one?
AUDIENCE: Stuff like this.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Oh, doing
stuff like this.
I give like--
I don't know-- four or
five talks a year.
So I think my next talk is--
I think it's next
month in WPPI.
It's a big convention
in Las Vegas.
And then I've been asked to come
down to Disney and give a
talk to the imagineers.
It'll probably be a group just
like yourselves, all PhDs with
a sense of humor.
At least I saw some smiles.
That's good.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So I'm a little
disappointed.
I don't see your rig.
I was kind of hoping you would
show us how heavy it was.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: If I wasn't
going to Nicaragua, I actually
would have brought it.
Yeah.
I had planned on bringing it.
AUDIENCE: How heavy is it?
And do you feel like you've got
some special muscles for
carrying it that most
people don't?
It's kind of funny, in this
world, where everyone carries
their iPhones.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Do me a favor.
Stand up.
OK, so that's you,
and this is me.
I'm huge, right?
So if I put--
the backpack, without any
camping gear in it, is
probably pushing
55, 60 pounds.
If I'm going out for a
week or more, it'll
pop up to 110, 120.
Right now I'm carrying what
I call my survival layer.
And so if I--
get it, right?
So if I carry that camera out in
the woods for a few weeks,
the survival layer goes
away really fast.
AUDIENCE: And how do you
fly with the camera?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: I put it in
one of those foamy deals.
I take the whole thing
apart, lenses.
I lock it up and throw it
on there and pick it up.
And then I leave that usually
at the airport, because you
can do that, and put
everything in my
backpack and then go.
Yeah, pretty slick some of the
stuff you can do these days.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How many miles
do you hike a day?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: When
I'm in the field?
Not when I'm sitting at
my desk in my office?
OK.
Well, on average, I'm
probably back about
11 miles, on average.
There's a lot of stuff that's
easy to get to.
There's some stuff that's not
too hard to get to, a day or
two to get into.
And then there's some stuff
that's two, three
weeks to get into.
So on average, I guess
I'm probably--
well, on Sunday I had a
friend from Moscow.
He came to visit.
And he's like, I want
to go shoot.
And I'm like, it's fricking
24 degrees outside.
What?
Yeah, let's go up
in the gorge.
So I thought, fine.
I'll take him on this
little hike.
It's two miles in,
two miles out.
I have what I call the
two mile rule.
At two miles all
the jerks stop.
They do.
Because they're like,
do, do, do--
two miles.
Oh my gosh, that's four miles.
I don't want to-- four miles.
This tail we went on was
just covered with ice.
There's a part where you've
got to hold the
cable to get by.
And it's like this wide.
And it was just a
sheet of ice.
And as we're going through--
his name is Dimitri.
He's from Russia, so he's
probably used to some ice.
I'm like, are you having fun?
Because it was dangerous.
It was really dangerous.
But on Sunday I did a
four miler, just a
nice little day hike.
Yeah, in the back.
Oh, hold on.
I'm getting two people.
We'll start here, and then
we'll come to you.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
dangerous situations?
RODNEY LOUGH JR:
Do I have any--
AUDIENCE: Dangerous
situations.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Have I had
any dangerous situations?
I kind of think the black bear
was pretty dangerous.
One of my favorite sayings is,
when I'm doing workshops--
because some of places we go to,
there's no fence, and I'm
like, this is life.
That is death.
Right?
There are absolutely
situations.
I don't have it to show you, but
there's this photograph I
have of me standing on this
precipice, where the rock
comes back underneath.
And it's easily like
a 1,200 foot drop.
But that was the only place I
could get the angle I wanted.
so I went out there.
I think you have to have a
couple missing screws to do
some of the stuff I do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How do you sell
your photographs?
What is your business model?
On your website, I couldn't
see that you had these
"dropped in a basket" tactics.
How do you sell these
photographs?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: I currently
have four galleries.
I have one up in Happy Valley.
I have one in Sausalito.
I have one in Las Vegas.
And then I have one
at Fisherman's
Wharf in San Francisco.
So my own galleries primarily.
AUDIENCE: I see.
So you don't sell online?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Not right now.
No.
Our website used to
do online stuff.
But what we discovered, from
our collector base, is they
really just wanted to look at
the images and then call one
of the people at the gallery
and make their final
decisions that way.
So we tried to make our new
website, which is up and
running right now, to be more
artsy, I guess, and less
commercial.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned taking
people out on workshops,
photography clients--
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Not
British people.
I'm joking.
AUDIENCE: Can the Americans
[INAUDIBLE]?
So everyone's been to
the same place.
They've all been exposed
to the same landscape.
I'm curious as to how their
different shots compare.
In other words, how much of it
is being there, and how much
is having the right eye?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Remember,
we were talking
earlier about talent.
I've actually looked through a
lot of other people's cameras
over the years.
And some people absolutely
have it,
and some people don't.
All right?
And I can't explain why that is,
other than this concept of
we all have different
talents, right?
But I've had five, six people on
this side of me, five, six
people on the side of me.
We're all looking at
the same thing.
And I go look at their cameras,
and every single one
of them is different.
It's really unique, actually.
It's kind of fun.
Anything else?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: When and why do
you choose nature to
be your main subject?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: When and why
do I choose nature to be my
main subject?
Have you spent much
time out there?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Yes, OK.
Well that would be the short
answer, wouldn't it?
I think that there is a
peacefulness and a calming,
serene feeling that
can only come from
being in these places.
I don't know what a typical
workspace here at Google looks
like, but I'm assuming
you have a cube.
You have a cube, or is it
just-- yeah, cubes.
Everyone's got cubes.
Let me tell you something.
We weren't designed to work
and live in cubes.
We weren't designed to
walk on concrete.
We were given grass.
That's what we're supposed
to be walking on.
It's OK that not everyone gets
to do what I do, because that
means I don't run into as many
people when I'm out there.
And I'm grateful to you guys.
I seriously am.
My guys at the studio were
working on Stand Here.
And your Google Maps
API, they love it.
If they could give you
guys a medal--
Any Google Map guys in here?
There was one, wasn't there?
Yeah, they'd give you a map--
or a medal.
They totally would.
They love you guys.
But no, I do it because I
love being out there.
Absolutely.
I just grew up with
it, I guess.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: How many people
in your crew?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: I have, right
now, pushing 50 people that
work with me.
And I say with me as opposed
to for me, because often
they're doing a lot of
things for me that I
don't even know about.
And they can only do that
when they work with you.
Do you understand the-- do you
guys understand what I'm
saying, the difference of
working for somebody and
working with somebody?
My people are working with me.
And I love it.
We've tried to create an
environment of people--
remember, I talked about
the two-mile rule?
Well, the people that you meet
beyond the two miles are what
I call earth muffins.
Come on, they've got
the dreadlocks.
The women don't shave
their armpits.
You know what I'm
talking about?
These are earth muffins.
I work--
even though they don't have
dreadlocks, and they do shave
their pits, I work with a
bunch of earth muffins.
They're like the sweetest,
nicest people on the planet.
I have a great life.
I really do.
One more question, then
I think we're done.
AUDIENCE: So how has
this sort of--
I feel like in the last decade
or so, there's kind of an
increase in democratization
of photography.
I feel like more people have
pro-level photography gear in
their hands.
More people are taking pictures
with lesser cameras,
all the way down to
iPhones and stuff.
How is that affecting the demand
for your products in
your business?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Actually,
it's improved it.
The question was--
I don't know if you guys
heard it or not.
There's a lot of people out
there with cameras.
There's a lot of people who
fancy themselves as
photographers.
How has that affected
my business?
Actually, it's helped it.
Because when you look at what
other people have for the
price points that they charge,
and then you come look at
mine, it's like a no-brainer.
If you've never been to my
gallery in San Francisco, it's
not that far away.
Has anyone been there?
OK, so you even know what I'm
talking about, don't you?
AUDIENCE: I think it's worth
pointing out though to people,
it's different to look at the
pictures in the gallery than
it is online.
He has lighting in the gallery
that makes a big difference.
And the size of the prints
make a big difference.
RODNEY LOUGH JR: Let's be
clear about one thing.
I take photos.
You take pictures.
[LAUGHTER]
RODNEY LOUGH JR: I'm just
messing with you, man.
I don't--
he's probably like the senior
VP of all of Google or
something, isn't he?
Screwed that.
AUDIENCE: Does a different
fraction--
is the fraction of money that
you get coming more from the
workshops and less from the
photos or anything like that?
RODNEY LOUGH JR: No.
The fine art photography is
where I make my money.
Yep.
That's where we feed the
kids and pay the
orthodontist bills.
And that's where it's at.
What we're doing with Stand
Here, we actually don't know
that we're going to
make any money.
We don't want to
lose any money.
But by the same token,
we think it's a
greater mission, right?
It's not about making
gobs of money.
It's about making people's
lives better.
In the end, that's ultimately
what I want to be remembered
by, protecting truly beautiful
places and making people's
lives better.
Is that such a horrible thing
to have on your tombstone?
I don't think so.
All right, I think we're done.
I want to thank you guys
for having me out.
Really appreciate it.